I'm sure you're going to be
interested in this,
because with more perspective now,
I want to bring in Michael Rothfeld.
He is a Pulitzer Prize.
Winning his work
helped to trigger
this whole investigation.
And so we're so glad to have him.
He is also the author of The Fixers,
The Bottom Feeders, Crooked Lawyers,
Gossip Mongers
and Porn Stars
Who Created the 45th president.
We're so happy that you're here.
Thank you for doing this,
because let's start
with the counts, right.
There are 34 of these counts
of falsifying
business records in the first degree
after working on this story for years.
Did you think that
this day would ever come?
Actually, no,
because this
you know, the federal authorities
were investigating this.
They charge Michael Cohen,
Donald Trump was president.
He couldn't be charged.
And then, you know, after he left office,
it did not seem like
it was going to happen.
And then Alvin
Bragg resuscitated the case.
So I didn't think it was going to happen.
And in the context that we have
now related to the invoices, relates to
the checks are going relate
to Cohen, relates to the ledger entries.
Did you know
specifically or have some idea
where this might go?
Well,
as my colleagues
at The Times
were reporting
on what the grand jury
was going to indict him for
and what the D.A.
was going to charge him with.
We did know that it was going to be
falsifying business records
and all of this
this scheme to repay Cohen
and disguise the repayment
for the Stormy Daniels
payment as legal fees.
That was known from the beginning.
So let's go let's go to the hush money.
There it is right there.
Three hush money
cases in the Trump
a dime in this McDougal.
But this is the checks
that you were referencing there.
These are right.
This is the evidence here. Right? Right.
And you can see that, you know,
Donald Trump
signed these checks himself.
I mean, his signature is illegible.
Some of the checks were signed
by other people.
I believe
Allen Weisselberg,
his CFO, may have signed some of them
or Donald Trump Jr.
Right.
But
some of these, Michael
Cohen says were signed
when Trump was in the White House.
You know,
every people who are saying, well,
you know,
even with this, the case isn't strong,
it would have it.
Does that matter at this point?
Because it does show
that the former president
was involved,
that Weisselberg was involved,
and there were others
who were involved in this.
Yeah.
I mean,
falsifying business
records is a pretty common charge
in New York state.
And clearly,
Michael Cohen did not perform legal fees.
He paid Stormy Daniels off
and he was repaid
with these sort of phony
checks for legal fees.
So that
that seems like a pretty
straightforward case.
You know,
the question is to elevate this
to a felony in New York State,
you have to show that he had the intent
to conceal another crime and that crime.
Alvin Bragg yesterday suggested
it could be a state
or federal election law violation,
some kind of a tax charge.
But, you know, he didn't specify that.
And I think he just has to show
that he had the intent to do that.
Let's talk about
what's in the indictment,
because the indictment does not name
the alleged crimes
Trump was trying to conceal.
But Bragg at his press conference
referred to violating state election law.
Did this surprise you?
No, because
I mean that while the state
or federal election law,
we don't really know
exactly what might
be said at the trial, but
the whole purpose of this
alleged scheme was to influence
the 2016 election for Donald Trump
and to silence these women,
Karen McDougal and Stormy Daniels.
The indictment itself
only deals with the Stormy
Daniels repayment
but in this accompanying
statement of facts,
Alvin Bragg lays out this larger scheme
of hush money payments
to help Donald Trump
during the 2016 election
and these are this is up.
These are all the three people
who are trying to be involved
in this right.
We understand
what happened with Stormy Daniels
that was the $130,000.
This was $150,000 Right.
And but
go on
and explain this
because the doorman thing
people are a bit confused about that.
Right.
Well so
Trump is alleged to have conspired
with David Pecker
who ran the National Enquirer
and the doorman Dino.
His name is Dino Juden.
He came to the Enquirer
with a story of Trump having a lovechild,
which he apparently did not have.
But in order to prevent the doorman,
he used to work at Trump Tower
from talking about this
during the election,
the Enquirer paid him $30,000.
And he he's he had to remain quiet.
You know,
let me just
before we go,
as you have been watching
all the coverage in the analysis here,
is this something that we're missing?
And people saying it's not a strong case?
I don't understand.
They're not
they're not listing an underlying crime.
Are we missing anything with this?
What would you like to point out
again?
Just that
this is a very common
charge in New York state.
Many people are charged
with falsifying business records.
And so what the D.A.
has said is that,
you know,
Donald Trump is no different than them.
I mean, it doesn't
it's not really that unusual
except for the fact
that he was the president
of the United States
and no former
president has been charged before.
But you know, that isn't that doesn't
necessarily make him immune
to prosecution. Michael, thank you.
I appreciate you joining us.
Michael Roth, though.